yo I'm Captain
America I got these guys hooked these
kids love me we did the bean bag TOS I'm
doing the cool stuff I'm posing I think
showing off my deep throat skills is the
next thing to go my big finisher my big
finisher is my big
[Applause]
finisher
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect
yo at least it wasn't like a DMX sound
to start off just as I was trying to
talk that's good but you know let's keep
it what's up guys I am Thomas dope as
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to dope as usual podcast I am here
with my co-host Marty O'Neal what up
folks sup that was
soft that was we did four intros to the
podcast today we did four Marty's here
to serve UT and do stretches the way he
just talked right now how are you how's
everything going guys let's get over
some quick updates then we're going to
get straight into some stories um oh
yeah Rosie got her braces off yesterday
or two days ago for the I mean it's been
eight
years I can't imagine almost eight years
and everybody asked like why because our
first dentist we had to sue cuz he was
just leaving him on and going back
adjusting here adjusting there adjusting
he got sued by like 40 something
patients cuz he was just taxing people
and Merc said yeah Dr prop sucks so we
got all of our money back and then she
had to start again but how many years
was that that was three and a half years
and we were driving back from LA to
Merced CU she didn't want to switch her
doctors when we moved to LA we were
going back we're using his excuse to
visit but yeah she got him off finally
which is wild finally off besides that
yeah right the second this episode is
over literally the second it's over I'm
getting on
I'm getting into Uber I'm going straight
to to Vegas me and Rosie are going to go
hang out we're going to go hang out for
a couple days we we for our anniversary
we never do anything we never go
anywhere so we decided a month later
we're going to go do something for our
anniversary so yeah we're going straight
to Vegas after this I'm not working I'm
not doing an event I'm not bringing my
camera I'm not doing anything I'm just
going so that's going to be really cool
that's going to be fun um many years
about 12
wow three high schools three high
schools yes three High School grips
that's
crazy high school is such a lifetime
high school then you get out and then
four years just start oh yeah I remember
it was 10 days after my eighth grade
graduation I was walking in my grandma
to loris's house I took a right to the
bathroom and I went it's been 10 days
since I'm out of 8th grade wow what's
going to be like in 10 years mhm I
always do that like all right three
years later and I'll get that and go hey
it's been hey hey all right all right I
do that all the time I've been doing it
for I remember my 18 I was like a week
after I turned 18 I was walking to job
placement temporary job placement places
I didn't have a car y I was just I mean
I had a car but I didn't have a the
light I didn't have
a a license and I had to get it when I
was 18 any anyway it was Dumb and I was
walking across Merced and walking across
where I used to start where I started my
old drug business was I was walking
right and back and forth in front of my
old apartment with jus and um
yeah that's pretty much it so let's get
started let's start talking let's start
getting into some more stuff Marty I see
you have some see you have some notes
just a couple light notes Here guys this
is a nice December episode we're just
catching up real quick we got a couple
new guests booked generally December are
going to be mostly solo episodes because
people are out doing holiday things and
whatnot y we don't like to bother
anybody well we'll bother you we'll
bother you that's kind of a lie we do
yeah we'll bother you we'll be hey man I
just noticed you're in La I don't care
what where when we're h if you got the
if you you know if you got the chance
just let us know cuz remember guys um a
lot of people like why don't you just
just get Adam Sandler why don't you just
get Adam Sandler uhuh if it was that
like reachable he wouldn't be Adam
Sandler that is the point you can't just
go high-f five LeBron James because you
feel like it sure you know so like we I
think people think that we're we're
famous because people like you you go
get them go h
tell me do you know an inside person
maybe their manager cuz it's not just
public we'll hit you up yeah we'll hit
you up I'm shocked every time anybody
comes out in the DM and on the comments
but people are like man you get him hit
them up get on your show
like I will I I wish I can't just go
you're on sit down it doesn't work that
way could you imagine if I just walk up
to the Rock get over here sit down could
you imagine he say sorry sorry sorry
sorry I didn't realize I was in the
presence of wrestling Legacy like no
it's not I just swon bombed a lot in
sixth
grade yeah um we can't just do
that so we're trying but also December
is hard because people are doing stuff
people are going not everybody's from La
so they go back home the holidays you
know so we have can we yeah we we have
comedian Brad Williams next
Tuesday and also the same day we're
filming with the second episode with
Shan solo Franklin
um the last time he was here he was like
man you should move then I ended up
moving not far away from him and then
yesterday I'm looking for a new house
and I'm pulling up to the
gate and someone just honking at me I'm
like oh God all right and I was like oh
yeah I forgot you got a you got a new
car and it was Frank it was
Sean and uh it was just wild timing like
yeah I'm about to go probably move next
to you and it's it's the next block over
like it's the next block over and
um I thought that was that was very
random but uh what better timing like
this the second episode with him has
been kind of in the works for a while
but now that that GTA 6 trailer just GTA
6 just dropped let's let's get some
inside information that's looking like
it's going to be the Christmas episode
as well folks so we might put together a
nice little giveaway that would be
awesome all right so we're Brad Williams
solo Sean and onto our next topic if you
watched last week's episode we talked a
lot about a certain topic of the cookies
burner topic nothing bad was said we
just put it out there it was literally
called clear in the air for a reason it
just needed to be said because it got
too awkward for everybody asking so many
times and me just lying yeah I'm sure we
connect like you how goofy I feel going
that's not true that's not the truth
it's weird yeah not saying the truth is
very weird you don't want to ever be
like lying for somebody you don't know I
don't I'm like I'm lying just to say
face but not
mine anyway um put the episode
out right next
day P guy we actually talked to P guy in
about P guy in the episode so P guy
reached out changed some numbers and
then
um yeah I got a call from burner it was
very odd hearing him on the phone like
oh yeah huh weird I mean I know People's
music it's like yeah you know what I
mean it's very like oh it's your phone
voice oh you sound the same just rapper
[__] yeah you know what I'm saying
totally so uh yeah we just talked it out
man talked it out we went over exactly
what we needed to go over it is exactly
what I thought it was it exactly who I
thought it was everything wow down to
the tea and more actually and more soes
sounds like a whole movie yeah the stuff
I told you I mean we're not g to get
into everything but yeah yeah um sounds
like a movie and we we're fine right so
he's like all right come out we'll film
the episode BL Marty and I do not like
to film episodes outside of the studio
we lose our feel it's not us it's not
and plus I'm not taking all this
[__] you
imagine all right let's take these
lights cuz no no we need our look so um
he's super busy right now so me and him
talked about it the second he can come
to La we're going to film down here and
we'll get that episode out yeah he's
like all right we got a bunch of he's
like I know you like smoking so I got a
bunch of strains coming out we should
just chill and smoke like yeah I'm down
exactly exactly what it should be ex
exactly and he said what I said like
we're both California and brown
fol I
know I know that that is what I'm saying
like this is the ultimate should not
happen this is the ultimate awkwardness
that should not be anyway um yeah cool
he just dropped a new project with OJ
ojz yeah we were supposed to get we were
talking to OG's manager uh he I was
getting the stuff from OG today OG is
linking me with ogz which is kind of
funny the cover art for the [__] a sick
yeah it is it's really nice so yeah
we're supposed to get ogz on soon
too lot in the works guys Lots lot of
stuff from the works but yeah that leads
us into the end of December and yeah we
just we're pumping out some solos I hope
you guys like them well how long have we
been here about 15 I think we're okay
yeah and if you have any questions for
Brad or if you have any questions for
Franklin drop the questions for
Franklin anything you want to know about
Grand Theft title 6 and he's allowed to
talk about we're going to talk about
this is an exclusive GTA interview we're
friends now right like last time we were
Star Struck damn near when you came in
here I me I you so much I knew I yeah I
knew Sean very well but no he know now
it's like no he's been my house like
five times been chilling been in his
house all the time I see him all the
time I follow I see his [__] on
Instagram every day I'm always like he
his brother lives right next door like a
couple houses away from me so I see him
often he passes by I always see him he's
always showing love in shows yeah he's
dude I pulled up on him on the freeway
and he was wearing a podcast
shirt wow I was on the entrance he
rolled the window down like oh and again
he got another car I was like oh who's
this fool honking at me R oh what's up
[Laughter]
Goes My Life man this is crazy also real
quick something that made me I don't
know if you saw it in the live chat
somebody I asked him five times to
explain it somebody's like yo Tommy
Chong was in my dispensary yesterday in
Arizona and I brought you up and he says
he's so excited to be on the show
because he could spread his message to
the younger audience wow and he says he
loved being on the show the fact that he
remembers me and I was like he
remembered us goes I got to be honest at
first he's like which show of course I
don't know that name and he goes the two
dudes one of them from Merced oh yeah
yeah yeah dope as dope as usual with the
shirts cuz he wore a shirt during the
Rams game and they had him on the
Jumbotron with dope as usual on which is
crazy and uh that made my whole day yeah
crazy that made my whole day he's like
sing said mer said he goes oh yeah yeah
yeah with the with the all the colors I
go yes with all the colors on the wall
exactly it's hot that's Brandon yes
um very cool so cool that was very cool
um like when things like that happen or
when you get like uh really really
really nice comment you really got to
sit back and let it sink in yeah because
I screen comment will sting your heart
and then I erased it later stuff like
that is like wow that's wild [__] is
crazy happening like this oh yeah dude
anytime like that I scre screenshot that
on my computer cuz I'm on the computer
and then when I'm like oh you're out of
space I don't need the screenshot it's
okay I'll just all right soaked it and
stuff that that's how I do all when I
find screenshots it's usually on my
computer and I'm control something for
and I drag it and screenshot that
besides that oh real quick shout out to
everybody I think it was Will and Hills
at the tree spot the almost everybody
that worked there was a fan it was so
awesome what's that again there I was
getting a Christmas tree and almost like
like three or four Dudes that work there
were fans and I was so stoked they
helped you get a tree yeah sick yeah I
was getting a tree you got a real one
yeah threw that [__] in the back of the
AMG no Marty Ralph's truck oh okay no
Mar would not do that
ever get a fake tree yeah okay no we
almost got a 19t tree damn near oh no
five 15t tree but it was looked like a
the Charlie Brown one it was all like
this it wasn't full it looked like a
bonsai tree almost it was so thingin and
I was like wow I've never had a huge
tree the one you got is so sick no fit
when you showed Emmy the sound she made
of Christmas Joy was like wow that's why
Rosie got it we have no children there's
no children at our house but we have
like four homies with kids at are near
so Rosie got this crazy tree we did all
this Grinch stuff everywhere she got a
fake Grinch body that sits in the tree
so it looks like he's in your tree and
then a fake arm that's in it with the
hand so it looks like he's wrapping
himself in the tree to grab your
presence yeah oh also we are H we are
hiring a grinch
impersonator for Johnny our nephew and
we can't do it to Sophia John's daughter
she'll freak out we're gonna hire it's
only $30 an hour for Aaron to dress up
as a grinch no it's an actual guy that
with the outfit and everything and we're
going to have him break into our house
and steal all of Johnny's stuff in front
of him oh
[Music]
God yeah cuz we're up top so I'm like
who's here come on and we're going to
walk down and I told Rosie a second we
see him go I'm getting my gun and then
John's going to lose his
mind could you imagine a fullsize grown
man in a grinch it looks like the Grinch
looking
up taking all the presents I would be
scarred forever and then right after I'd
be like it's fake no you got to have a
big ass Nerf gun on Deck you'd be like
here take this hand it to him I'm go get
my gone see what he does oh he would
lose his he's going to lose his no he's
goingon to freak out he's definitely
going to lose his mind that's some
horrific dramatic [__] do to Christmas
he's not a little boy okay he's like
seven okay but he's 12 in his head this
is like I have full conversations with
this kid I I I would never do it to a
kid that would go ah and lose their mind
he's just going to freak out and like oh
my God it's R like he's just he's a boy
few moments of Terror a few he's going
to hold us di prank yeah yeah like the D
but not like that he's just he's going
to be funny or he or he just loves it
did I ever tell you about the Captain
America we hired for his Cam's birthday
one year no this [__] what
drunk I don't know what this fool was on
I got a video of it though uh he shows
up probably half hour we're like
wondering where he is to the point that
I'm getting ready to go to Walmart and
get some sort of costume come back as
Captain
America okay then finally he gets there
he comes over our back wall which was
completely unnecessary and super tall
and he like he literally wait your back
wall what was behind the
wall like a hill to the street did he
know did you talk to you prior yeah he
came and pulled up he finally saw him
and then he said I'm going to do my
thing he all right next thing we know
he's [__] he's falling over the top of
the wall cuz it's like a hill with trees
and stuff uh so literally you hear
everybody kind of looks over and he like
gets up and dust himself off and [__]
and now he's Captain America and he's
coming down our Hill completely
unnecessary so off top we're like all
right bro bro's late he's all disheveled
he comes over the wall like not expected
then he's just super like all over the
place with all his stuff
and then he pulls
out the balloons that you twist and make
animals with and never showed you this
video this is insane and he starts
deepthroating these
balloons Right Down the Hatch and
everybody's like stop April's whole
family my mom was there April's mom was
there everybody and they're like no he
didn't
mortified no he does it like twice he's
dancing around his button FL lies off
all kinds of wild shit's happening is he
in shape at least yeah he's bu you know
he's like a big lanky white dude he
looked like Captain America he wasn't he
jacked like look like me you know
so his costume was all wild and I'm
going to pop up a video I know I'm going
to be able to download it somewhere but
yeah this fool Captain America came
through and deep throated about three
three
Footers uh as his big balloon trick and
everybody
was like between uncomfortable and like
dying laughing you'll see in the footage
it real quick real quick breakdown we
were like he knows it's a kids party
he's Captain America I said I was saying
in the thing bro wrong
party all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyway wow wrong
[Laughter]
party so wait so Captain America he's
like
yo I'm Captain
America I got these guys hooked these
kids love me he did the bean bag TOS
doing the cool stuff I'm posing I think
showing off my deep throat skills is the
next thing to go my big finisher my big
finisher is my big
finisher that's the dumbest [__] I ever
heard Marty right why it was in real
life too we were we were shocked what
this was not what we I believe you about
the balloon thing cuz I told you I went
to Tim Burton I've talked about this
before I went to the Tim Burton
experience the restaurant the Tim Burton
restaurant never
go never go never ever ever ever waste
your money I went yeah the Tim Burton
exact I don't waste your money I went
about four years ago and all they did
was play Clips like a 4minute highlight
reel of different movies he's done on
the wall in a darker
restaurant i h I actually have the the
Yelp and I will show it I've talked
about this before the entertainment was
a girl that walked around the room table
to table and deepthroated balloons just
like you said so that's why I went oh
yeah okay I get it but I'm not done as
she as it's in
here she
goes pulls a pin out and Pops the
balloon in her throat and goes and
bows I assumed bro had a little pin
somewhere on his tongue or some [__]
that he was like letting the air out of
it cuz I'm like there's no no no no he
is deep gave him the benefit of the
doubt there's got to be some magic going
on he's deep thr again they were not
small B but but but like but if if we
have anybody in the comments that is a
balloon artist is that a feature that is
always taught like you like Adobe you
know like you know Photoshop you know
photo shooting like you know how to you
know how to clown back flips you know
giraffes know animals
deepthroating let us know let us know is
that a why I love that that was
incredible I don't know how we got on
the topic but we started off with Grand
Theft Auto and ended up on Captain
America deepthroating balloons at a kids
party I wish he was just drunk too there
had to be something that would have made
it better he might have been drunk a few
hours before he wasn't sloppy but he was
like clumsy and he was on one off of
something that sounds incred just in
general you're just you know your day
job is just you're just Captain America
with kids but you're just wild Captain
America with kids sounds good I like
that sound like a like the my book
Captain America but with
kids right meaning I beat the [__] out
of
kids yeah we're going to get flagged are
we going to get on let's get on this we
we we didn't even start what's popping
all right I see you put it on there
Tesla truck review so Marquez brownley
just did this did you say Mark as browny
the dude uh oh I thought you said Mark
ass brownie what the [__] a mark ass
brownie I swear to God is that a
YouTuber you know marcass brownie
reviewed this truck that's a cool
name he uh you
know super famous YouTuber dude oh he he
reviews cars He reviewed the new Cyber
truck that just came out so it's got
like 17 million views already something
ridiculous I mean all his reviews do
numbers like huge numbers with this is
like people been waiting on this it's
been four years since they first did
that in veiling of it and the window
broke yeah and now you're seeing Rogan
shooting bows at it they're filing I
didn't see that well he just went on
Elon just went on Rogan's podcast and
they shot arrows at it really yeah they
shot guns at it on the uh other thing I
saw online it's bulletproof I think it
is the car the virsion they shot looked
like it sure stopped the bullets like
the car car or the windows not the
window the car like it's like but isn't
that like the most logical thing like yo
every else don't get shot bulletproof
just my neck up hair to Pieces it's
worthless without the bulletproof
windows maybe they are it has to be dude
it's it's like one big piece of glass
all the way front and back it's the
biggest windshield wiper ever oh wow one
giant windshield wiper all complete
there's not a rounded line on it
it's got two
Motors goes 0 60 super
fast uh it looks like to me something it
doesn't have any branding on it no it
does it looks like a Mad Max apocalypse
it looks just like Mad Max okay so we so
100% agree okay so that's what that is
and it's not some minimalist modern
aesthetic okay so he did the review on
it it's it's out people can buy it now I
think maybe like if you bought it
they're starting to make them to get
your orders but it has like uh they put
like a liner in the back now so it's got
this giant like back flat bed I see the
back I see it at the uh it was it was
stainless steel when they first released
it now it's lined but you hit a button
and it goes up and then it like goes up
and down and it reveals like a back
window to the truck so it's like
automatic it's got power outlets back
there they got the front truck I saw
something you could charge a a you could
charge an electric car off the Tesla
truck
I saw something like that on Tik Tok
last night that you that has ports that
you could charge and El your car off the
truck they said Tesla was a battery
company that got into making cars you
know so that makes sense I get it I
don't I don't know much about this other
than watching his review he's great at
his reviews uh there's nothing crazy
about it he's just very to the point and
clean in his explanation of things but
uh I wanted to get your take on this
truck what are your thoughts on it is it
ugly is it stupid is it cool I think
it's ugly but cool looking and I think
think ugly but cool looking is like the
kind of shoes I like uhhuh EXA the Lil
Wayne Supras are my favorite shoe almost
and they were the ugliest weirdest
looking Moon boot you ever saw but I
love them and I still have them I'll
never get rid of them
so do you think seeing them on the
streets are they going to noral yeah I
saw well no I saw at the Museum it had
the S the the ATV that goes in the back
it comes with the ATV it was pretty cool
see that yeah matched the car and
everything it was pretty cool yeah it
matched it it was sick um I think
they're cool I don't I don't I was just
talking about this the other day don't
care about electric cars don't care I
will not get one until it is necessary
and or forced upon me because if I need
to get away and I go give me 28 minutes
got to
charge no and I just made this point the
other day cuz Trent is a just preaches
how much Tesla's so much much better
than everything that's all Trent talks
about and he goes what about the
apocalypse man blah blah blah I'm like
in the apocalypse I will go to a gas
station and dig up the ground and siphon
the gas out if I have to so the pumps
won't work without electricity I'm I
will figure that out I I can bust
through the ground eventually it'd be
sick if they had solar on them well and
he said what about solar I go well I
don't know how to use that I don't how
to harness energy but what if it was
just built into the car per he's said
what about solar panels on the car and
go perfect yeah that is I'm surprised
it's not like that that's why I said
that's that's perfect but don't tell me
that when I go home on go to Merced when
I go to last year when I went to Merced
and every year before when I go back
there is a mile and a half long line of
Teslas waiting to use the charging
station right off the Grapevine how many
miles is it there you know you get 350
miles on this I'm not sure but it needs
a charging
yeah hours to wait to charge that's
crazy that's insane oh my 4-Hour trip
turned into six I would hate that so
much I wouldn't do that I'd rather pay
more I I'll pay you more I'll pay you
more for gas just so don't have to wait
two hours with everyone over there just
sitting in a line oh thank you I guess
it's good if you never go anywhere I
could go make the money to make the gas
in the time I waited to charge my car to
save the money for the gas yeah
no is the mayback horrible on gu
surprisingly
no nope not at all how much take to fill
it
out like maybe like
120 but it's 91 yeah so it's not bad I
thought you were going to say something
ridiculous no it's not bad Ro's car is
like 90 yeah not bad at all I mean for a
V12 do you got them both back in working
condition now nice there's at the house
nice that the house chilling um so yeah
test the truck
review it looks cool
not for me when when when when it comes
time we'll go on there it looks Giant on
the interior it's got uh the seats are
different so the person sitting behind
you can like really comfortably slide
their back feet under the seat oh that's
cool uh so couple little things but yeah
it looks good in a zombie apocalypse for
sure yeah zombie apocalypse I'll unless
those windows aren't bulletproof what
are we doing but then again can you
really have bulletproof windows yeah
yeah yeah I guess you can just hell of
bulletproof
windows there hell bulletproof cars h
hell yeah it's not even that much it's
like 70k to bulletproof your car I think
I mean not that much I'm saying if
you're making if you need a bulletproof
car you're probably making so much damn
money that 70k is like here wait hold on
here here's the rest of it you know um
okay WTF of the week a new segment and I
know nothing about it cuz it's just vom
if this is about stuff that's going to
get us flagged Marty this is Sports Talk
it's not though cuz I think you're going
to talk about violence hold on let me
just air this you're about to talk about
violence and what happened to to the
April Ro Rosie episode age restricted
immediately why because we talked about
about puffy cols all right all
right we gave this fool I think I think
I saw 120 million I could be six-year
deal wow like we could have did so much
with that so the bills picked up Von
Miller yeah in 20 2 2 okay and he's been
hurt ever since he tore his ACL
immediately and he's been sitting out
and sitting out I think he might have
seen a few minutes I really If he if he
has played I I haven't really heard his
name I he's just getting ready to come
back he was cleared to play we got the
Chiefs coming up we just went and lost
beat ourselves against the Eagles uh
last week and now we got the Chiefs
coming up and we were supposed to have
Von Miller back in full force but he
yeah went and caught a case related to
violence within the home oh that was a
great way to put it yeah great way to
put it he bches up I like the way you
put it bch is not a cuss word yeah and
uh the bills are are like we're going to
let the justice system justice system
play this out he's still on Bo I think
he's still gonna
play yeah I think he went to jail I
could be I didn't look super deep into
this but it's just the you know WTF of
the week brutal is this all
CTE why is it so many so many athletes
like you're trained and it's just it's
your second nature to just slam people
like you're a professional body Slammer
yeah it's so you're close to violence I
guess so just in your wiring I don't see
how you can be like I married you I'm
going to throw you through this wall I
was telling
earlier uh I was telling cam about my
boy Doug I showed my boy that went to
the NFL I went to high school with I
showed him his picture he posted the
most gangster picture all time him in
like his living room he's got just giant
trophies lining up the whole all sides
of the uh frame and stuff and I was
trying to describe to cam how different
he was in high school how everybody knew
he was going to be the one that goes and
like him just like he was just barely
wrestling around with this kid in the
locker room kid was my size but yo
brick back jacked
shredded Doug just playing around with
him picks him up ho him up up through
the ceiling tiles knocks all the ceiling
tiles out brows up in the ceiling and
like
accidentally Doug's like six7 you know
he did seven years in the
league lineman offens lineman some
something like that I don't know all the
positions but yeah anyway my point is
like I could see how you're close you
have a crazy temper you could easily
hurt somebody I don't know the details
of it but all I'm saying is what the
[__] of the week bro for 120 mil let's
just get you on the field and like be a
superstar that we know you can be that's
all I want same with Diggs he's starting
to do it Diggs was quiet for a very long
time starting to get back in the mix a
little bit Josh is starting to do his
thing we could have beat the Eagles last
week very easily we were beating the we
were beating them bad and the we beat
ourselves in the second half
foosball I haven't watched one I watched
eight minutes the other no sh watched
four plays the other day it's the most
I've watched this whole season it's
crazy it was Sunday morning and I woke
up the Sunday morning went let's watch
football went downstairs went I'm good
watched it for a c plays
went you got you got to start placing
some bats this week go that way and I
went to my kitchen yeah um that's when
April started carrying when she started
doing little betting stuff that just
means I'm stressing I don't know about
caring I think just like just come on I
don't like that uh I like hate watching
I talk [__] about your colors your city
your coach who looks like uniform about
your colors your branding your I mean
your city and your
logo um in ninth grade we were doing the
powerlifting you know for football and
this kid Richard he was like 6'5 we're
in freshman year he lived he lived by me
and Anthony Avala and I
remember he was so big and just awkward
he was a giant kid like a big kid he
wasn't a skinny 65 he was a big 65 and
we were doing power clean no power clean
the the lift
yeah over the head no no right catch
come up mhm and I was doing like that
was my that's my worst lift I don't have
this this Bend right here my wrists
don't bend more than that it's like it's
hard for me to power clean so I can't
really hold it see all this is hurting
already since I was younger I can't do
it
anyway I was doing like
170 not a lot but it's it's a lot I was
doing like 170 you know as freshman year
I was about I was doing it I got under
there and it's a it hurt and Richard it
was like his first day lifting with us
he was doing bench he's a weak ass upper
upper body I don't know what happened he
was not very big but he was squatting a
lot he's one of those guys that's so big
His Feet go sideways when he
runs one of he was a 65 giant giant
lineman right I remember I'm like dude
try the power clean he's like oh I'm
like so you go down I'm showing him how
to do it he's so big and awkward he's
going to have to do like a jack knife to
get up he's like so big that he's G he's
not going to fluidly come up he's just
and he's like a husky
dude and I remember like dude the goal
is pick it up as hard as you possibly
can drop your body under it don't try to
pick it up to your chin try to get it up
to your chest drop under it catch
it that's how you power clean that's how
you do that's how you see him drop so I
did I showed
him and this fool gets under goes I'm
like as hard as you can drop under I
should have put 250 on didn't know this
kid just goes hits himself right in the
face of the bar knocks himself almost
out clean backward off the squat I mean
off the little platform right on his
back bam drops the weight and everything
he just goes
was D near knocked himself asleep dude
knocked himself right in the top of the
teeth no I swear to go it was too light
and he was like expecting it to like ah
and he just went hit himself right in
the face fell back it was the funniest
thing I've ever seen he wasn't concussed
or anything but
um the next day they moved him to JV
they're like dude you're too big you're
we need you we need you not on the
freshman team I'm sorry the next year
they move him to Varsity not JB they so
as a sophomore at the end of freshman
year they're like you're going to be on
the senior team he's too big but yeah I
saw him almost break his teeth out I got
bumped up to Varsity my freshman year
for playoffs for basketball damn I got
in at the uh end of the game and airball
the free
throw did you
really as you say that I dropped my
mouthpiece in the
ash just as you did the sound
effect
a
[__] that's okay two years in a row I
uh struck out with Bases Loaded down by
three D in baseball same team same
pitcher same
school I I in Middle School two plays
back toback moved on the F line while
somebody
was yo y the parents were like
bro I didn't really realize you couldn't
do that so much I mean I knew it but
like okay bro had the ball then you like
move spots like a spot closer to him and
then I was like flustered they called
The Penalty on me gave the ball and I'm
like [__] I tried to like move spots
again that might have been freshman year
two freshman year I almost I I had I'm
in center and it was on three and I on
Two And I already stuttered and I tried
to go back before anybody saw it I
went cuz I to move you can't move the
ball at all I can move my arm move my
body can't move my wrist or my ball so
what on three and I went on two and I
tried to put it back and my whole line
jumped my whole line
jumped and we got pushed back and I
looking like damn we're at the N9 yard
line this is not good now we're at the
four yard line okay I everybody looking
at me like full for real
hey forgot also I'm the captain I beat
all of you for your spot I will out
benge all of you shut up that's first
mistake first mistake of the year right
shut up that's how I felt like don't
ever ever say some [__] to me fool I'll
school all you fools right now don't say
that criticize me one thing don't make
fun of me man cuz I didn't make fun of
you when you were third string yeah
everybody [__] up out there two guys
are hurt that's why you're in that's why
you're playing right now do you want me
to say that you're third string [__]
I went to IM on the bottom my boy khil
who I literally played with every day we
played games one1 games that took
multiple days the score went so high and
uh meaning we were just super familiar
with each other and I went to in bond to
them clean over his head out of bounds
did that stupid [__] one time that's
cool man see I told you not to bring
this y kid over here man that's his
first thing I know he just scored 60 but
told you not to bring him um so
embarrassing all that kind of shit's
embarrassing and what does this mean
Tommy G clip
clarification oh well I posted up this
cool clip with Tommy G yesterday so many
people didn't realize he had been on the
show like a lot of the people in the
comments were like bro I can't wait for
this [__] to drop so anybody that's
confused why this is a solo episode
today he was our first guest of season
we're in the other Studio we were at a
different spot different Studio we with
an agency um we went our separate ways
but there was 14 episodes with
them we didn't really put the episode
out like that because we didn't love
like was in 1080 as opposed to 4K the
audio mix was different so like that was
great episode but we really didn't put
it out we need another one with Tommy G
because he's like such a g even behind
the scenes he's making G moves all the
time just being a cool dude yeah so yeah
shout DJ Drama on too yeah we everybody
that exactly everybody we interviewed at
the other spot need to come back we need
to redo it I was just dming with drama
telling him we need Jack Carlo or
whoever he can out here you know he's
all tied in with Jack Carlo would be
cool
yeah yeah I'm down hey what's up guys
taking a moment to talk about one of our
sponsors and this is raw papers as you
can see I have a ridiculous Contraption
on my head but epic right now on
Instagram Go to Raw life2 247 let them
know dope as usual podcast sent you if
you guys already don't follow Raw on
social media they're constantly doing
giveaways constantly doing give backs
fan interaction art contests so go ahead
and make sure you follow them on Twitter
on Instagram and on YouTube last week we
did a $300 raw box giveaway shout out to
four Chuck Jones shout out to you for
winning the Box all you got to do is
follow our Instagram and follow raw's
Instagram we do collaborative post we're
just trying to give back to the fans
thank you for supporting us thank you
for smoking the brand we appreciate it
and it's Christmas time guys wouldn't
this make an amazing gift this is just
cool so go to rawthentic.com to check
out all items they offer this is one of
many ridiculous things there's a Frisbee
with a hole in it you can put a joint in
there and throw it to your homie raw
thank you for sponsoring the show thank
you for everything thank you for lacing
up all of our customers all of our
friends all of our fans thank you so
much once again Go to Raw life2 247 on
Instagram let them know the dope as
usual podcast sent you as always guys
thank you so much for supporting the
brands that support us have a dope ass
day hey what's up guys last week if you
watched the episode then you saw that
Marty and I won
$437 on my bookie the first time we've
ever bet and we won there's a lot of
football there's a lot of UFC going on
but one thing we don't talk about too
much that I think we should is my bookie
Casino they have a virtual casino on the
app Blackjack slots video poker Texas
holdom roulette there's tournaments
Christmas games there's much more than
just betting on millionaires running
down fields and hitting balls you can
try to become a millionaire yourself and
go bet on my bookies Casino click the
link below the video no matter what
platform you're watching click the link
with my bookie that's our link and if
you sign up spend $50 and my bookie will
match it 10% all the way up to $200
deposit listen to that if you're already
signed up for my bookie make your friend
sign up for my bookie and take advantage
of this brand new deal if you like to
gamble and you gamble online you might
as well gamble with my bookie and you're
supporting the do's usual podcast make
sure to click our link remember with
that link you bet $50 in your first
deposit my bookie will match you 10% all
the way up to $200 bet thank you for
supporting the brands that support us
shout out to my bookie back to the
episode okay so check this out
guys we're coming up on the end of
season five of story
time I don't know how to keep it going
without being stagnant or being the same
feel like I'm I'm it's getting harder to
like yo just tell a story on camera like
yeah but it's going to be age restricted
and blocked like what's I got to find a
new method then because I'm not going to
talk about it too
much I'm you guys know I'm I'm very you
know for my dope as old Channel my my my
YouTube channel is very restricted it
used to be not they just started
blurring all my thumbnails yesterday did
you see it no
no all of my thumbnails are
blurred until you open the video and
watch it but you'll never see the
thumbnail cuz you don't play the
thumbnail on the video so the thumbnail
you will never
see all of my thumbnails are now blurred
on YouTube totally blurred blurred can't
see a thing all right but you're logged
in there that's why yeah
unsubscribe no this is I'm in a
incognito window Oh
weird every single person it was all
blurred yesterday that would be horrible
oh no no I even posted the video cuz
same
thing some of his videos restricted or
something maybe if it's somebody who's
logged in who's not 18 that I don't know
that I don't know but here we
go very uphill battle right now I'm
trying to figure it out because a lot of
my videos are getting blocked the other
day I got 14,000 views in one day on a
video and I'm not sitting you're like
well fol maybe your videos suck I get
that I understand there was 3,000 people
in the chat
during the
live a lot that that automatically is
3,000
views it didn't make sense it got
blocked and restricted the second I
upload I'm like all right maybe I mean
that happens every time I've never seen
that happen so much that I took the
video down and re-uploaded it that's how
bad like it it didn't it didn't it's
like I never even posted the video mhm
so that happens once in a while with
like Facebook Tik Tok or something like
you post it nothing happens so you got
to re-upload it oh man I've never
experienced that so I'm like wow what am
I going to do what I have to do what I
have to do to change this I'm pumping
out content I'm I'm having fun and the
fan all the comments they're having
people are having fun so it's not like I
need to be worried about well maybe
people just don't want to watch anymore
I always think about that like well
maybe I need to change it up maybe I
need to grow maybe I need to excel maybe
I need to do this I need to try this and
I do that every the feedback is like bro
this is great it was thousands of
comments you know what I mean if I was
getting 40 comments be like damn you
need YouTube working for you in order to
grow on YouTube the thing cuz the other
day I released a video didn't get age
restricted for four hours and it got
90,000 views in four hours no 7 75,000
views in four hours like oh wow good
cool numbers age
restricted it didn't hit it hit like 90
for the next 20 hours so it only had
14,000 more in 20 hours for is 880,000
views almost in 4 hours but now it's at
like 250 which is still cool but do you
see like why you care about AG no it's
not a it's the blocking not suggesting
it stops no more no more page doesn't
come on your page anymore some people
don't even majority of your views in
general come from
suggestion yeah so the reason I'm
bringing this up is because I'm going to
re-evaluate everything you know it's
coming up at the end of the year I need
to reevaluate what I'm doing how I'm
going to do it how I'm going to approach
[__] yesterday's video we bleeped some
of the curing in the first minute and a
half it got age restricted immediately 4
hours later YouTube Just unage
restricted
it now it's at 100,000 views so
stupid in less than a day mhm like great
those are cool numbers man thank you for
at least people are seeing it but when
I'm seeing 5,000 views in 6 hours I'm
like what happened sorry and I know
people Dan full all he cares about his
views it's not that it's your business
it's that it's my it's I've been
building this for so long that damn I
put this much work into it and now it's
not even being
shown I put in Hell work on these videos
man I watch other YouTubers having a lot
of subscribers used to mean something on
YouTube because you'd know like at least
250k are going to see this off top just
off law of averages if I have over a
million easy but it's really based on
more what's being suggested for sure but
for me it's it's more of this
guys
oh I did something wrong maybe maybe I
did something wrong in this video that
didn't catch people's attention they
didn't care and I say I do that same
video again the same everything and it
goes fine huge views It
Go where's the logic I just want to know
the logic I only want to know the logic
that's all I care you know oh you know
what I cussed in first eight oh my God I
said I cussed like that I showed a pound
less than 30 of course it's going to age
stct okay I get it okay but no dude
there's there there was a video of me
just just talking and it got age
restricted and I didn't even cuss I made
sure made sure of it it was actually
going to be for the adventure Channel
that's how much I didn't
cuss so I just try to find the logic
anyway I'm go I'm going through I was
going through one my old videos and I
was looking at it like wow man I used to
have no setup wow I used to do do this I
used to do that oh my God I can't
believe I used to do this and I'm not
saying it's bad it's just like wow how
much have we tried different things and
it worked it looks better that looks
better this looks better and then I
thought there's a lot of Stories Behind
these videos yes there's story times and
stuff but when I really look at the
video thumbnail I'm like wow I remember
that day I remember we did this I
remember that go that's a whole episode
of Story Time right there so right now
for the next couple the next 30 minutes
at least I'm going to walk you through
some some of my videos in the past 10
years all right some of my videos I'm
explaining you what's going on what
happened and there's a backstory to
every single one of these so let's get
started Marty can you start at the very
top so this first video this is my very
first YouTube video it's not a bunch of
Instagram Clips it's the first YouTube
video I ever did because I thought I do
so much in remember this is nine years
ago nine years ago the first video I
ever did on YouTube so this is what
happened I um I had a bunch of weed
stuff this is actually remember last
week I talked about when I was starting
to do the cookie stuff starting to run
Pages this video takes place about two
months maybe two and a half months after
that and I think some of the Edibles in
this video are from the store that I was
taking pictures for so it all it all
just goes together anyway this is nine
years ago I thought guys people
I thought this ready YouTube's a new
platform for me let me just drop a
regular smoking video I didn't know how
to make La forign content I never talked
on camera at this time this is before
video on Instagram before video I think
it was just pictures there was no DMs I
was making if if there was motion on my
page it was Stop Motion Pictures in
collages because there was no carousels
yet for Instagram so I had to post I
used SP a a pick collage app
so what happened here was I said Rosie
we get high as hell all the time what if
we started filming videos instead of
just taking pictures so this is my very
first shot at making videos and it is
about
12 13 minutes of Rosie and I just going
over smoking stuff going over our stash
because remember at this time guys I had
just stopped like selling so much
weed uh my guy had gone missing already
everything was slowing down I was in
college I was just about to start
working at this time I was just about to
start working at U-Haul so if you want
to see like the very beginning and the
push tre's house just seeing this back
room it's where a lot of the pictures
you've ever seen were taken right in
this spot it just I don't know I wanted
to talk about it as this is the intro of
me doing video this the first time I
ever talked I think on camera never did
videos never did anything I think Vine
had just started coming out out I said a
few words during a video there was an
ongoing joke at this is the highest most
quiet man on the planet the highest uh
what was it the highest mute dude on the
planet cuz I never said a word I never
said a word on camera because there was
no video so go ahead and check it out
it's called wake and bake number one I
just want to go over it real quick and
uh yeah go check that out it's the push
tre's house Marty can you go up to the
next
one
okay all right this one you should go
watch on YouTube cuz I've never seen
anybody else do something like this on
YouTube This is called 100 lbs of weed
cush UPS so uh cush UPS we started
talking about and now like there's a
trend cush UPS is the whis Khalifa thing
you hit as much as you possibly can or
10 seconds or something I don't remember
it's like a Whiz Khalifa thing but I
don't know I called these push-ups this
a long time ago so six years ago this
video actually and we're not going to
play it herez we'll get just get flagged
you go watch these videos on the dop
YOLO Channel here's the backstory of
this
video before I got so and it kind of
makes me sad though but before I got so
busy with all the companies and before I
got so busy filming and do all this
stuff I'd be sitting there and my brain
would just be thinking of stupid
[__] but cinematically stupid [__] so
you remember the And1
commercial and it was the dark
technically it was
Nike that's not cool that's lame that's
lame but you're right but remember they
made fun of the commercial in Scary
Movie 2 yeah yeah so that I was thinking
I don't know I don't remember where I
was but I thinking ooh this real close
cinematic dark shots on the coming in
and out of frame I really like that and
you know what you know what I like I
like that Colin Kaepernick commercial oh
you know what I like that I like the
Michael Vic Nike commercials back in the
day you know what El commercial this is
when that commercial came out where it
was a hockey player turns into a
baseball player turns into remember that
commercial that came out and it was like
the the track
runner takes off and you just see the
shoe take off from the gun and I was
like I'm gonna do that for some weed so
that's what this video
is all all right ready real quick I used
to edit every video on my phone on
iMovie this is edited on iMovie all
right all sound the reason why all my
sound on every single video every single
video up to
2018 why all the sound sounded a little
not
crisp it's it's because every single the
music on this I played on my phone on
Rosie's phone and I pressed record on
iMovie and I would do this everybody be
quiet beep done okay that's how I
recorded the sound over my whole video
for five minutes be quiet you know how
many times I've been on the
freeway holding phones together so I can
record and Export it's insane I've
edited the whole Black Market Vlog you
can check that out the black market La
Vlog I edited while driving T mer
said I was driving M and and I edit the
video the whole time Mar like this
knee space cut that's wild was [__] cut
cut Rosie if you see any crazy break
light you tell me that's how I would do
it m cuz I'm paying attention but I'm
not paying attention I'm not going to
crash unless I'm looking down but I'm
not I'm always hold the phone right here
but I'm always like you see cops let me
know cuz I'm
just you know what I mean I got I had
some weed on me I got to be careful I
edit the whole Black Market Vlog while
driving anyway this video I thought you
know let's do some Nike [__]
so this is at Bob's
house Bob's the only person I know that
much way of the time that I can just go
use so Bob from season one this is this
is his house oh gotcha yeah this is the
interview with the drug dealer is he one
of the highest UPS you've dealt with in
terms of like had the
most yeah
probably um Cuz 100 lounds of weed to
him back remember it's been like this is
so long ago and no no
no I mean I can't talk about everything
but he's he has a legal like he's a
legal company like he still sees weed
and stuff yeah he still sees weed and
stuff so it's like 100 lb is not a big
deal yeah he's always going to have
wheat but I was like you got 100 lb and
he
goes no I I can get it here real quick
if you want to go all right can I use it
for a video goes of course come over he
loves that [__] cuz he's like a Family
Guy now he's like all legit you don't
get to see cool [__] like that no more
half of these packs were legal
like Dro gotcha half these facts are
illegal so uh anyway I did this video we
go go watch it it's so stupid it's
so dumb but it made me laugh and I'm
curling I'm literally curling 100 PS so
no matter what I can curl 100 we know
that like I'm like 100 and I'm just
sitting there
just for some reason 100 PBS of weed is
so much lighter than 100 lb of weight of
like metal weight and know that makes no
sense and no one anyone that's never
seen the show before is going the this
guy's a
idiot I understand throw a 100 pound
weight at me I'm going to die throw 100
pounds of weat at me I'll be all right
but yeah I filmed this video with Trent
I have a video of me filming we cut open
some turkey bags so he could film
through bags so it look we got some good
shot we built it he has a track the
track like from the sand lot that they
build the track on but you know for
cameras the track from the night I met
you basically that track that Trent was
filming on yeah yeah that we used for
this stupid weed video it's a minute and
37 seconds long as for
Instagram back when I could post weed on
Instagram
uhuh isn't that nuts dude we he had the
whole filming track just to film me
thake curling smoking joints I did the
Dust the macro shot of the bar as I came
up grabbed it with my fingers yeah Trent
had like the most highle gear you could
have at that time for no reason for no
reason at all but yeah 100 pounds of
wheat you got to check that video I just
wanted to go over I don't know I was
just thinking about like yo I I want to
talk about a little bit about each of
these cuz people always ask about story
times but I was thinking there's stories
behind all the videos how much stuff
happened during Crazy shit's happened
during videos too and how many new fans
have come around in the past six years
true true so go ahead and check it out I
thought it was funny um all right can go
on to the next this video is called
throwing 4 lbs of weed in a fire
pit do you want to know what it's
about wow a minute and 47 seconds long
these are all like well these are all
for Instagram I only made Instagram
clips and I was like oh I have YouTube
throw it up on YouTube like igtv that's
exactly what I used it for I didn't care
about YouTube I didn't care about long
form content this I filmed on my phone
all right ready throwing four lbs of
weed in the fire pit I was at my homie's
house my homie used to make oil right
and if you know anybody makes oil or you
make oil and it's not a facility usually
a lot of black trash bags stacked on top
of each other there's probably a lot of
stems and
Shake by the bags and there's always
some bags in the back that you never
blasted because it wasn't that good but
you wanted to get rid of it but you
didn't get rid of it so it got old and
then you felt bad about getting rid of
it but you didn't want to throw it away
cuz it was weed and you didn't want to
use it because you didn't want to use it
because it was trash but also you can't
just throw away weed your principles but
you don't want to make Trash did you
like that breakdown I felt that okay so
those bags in the very back that's what
kind of play you know what I mean like
if you make oil probably dirty in your
garage I'm not saying everybody's dirty
but I'm just saying like there's a lot
of old trash 50 lbs of shake that nobody
wants to run back then at least my homie
looked at me and he goes bro I have all
this
weed and it was way more than 4 lbs I
just put four lbs cuz I know like I kind
of guessed it but I want to like that's
not 7 lbs it was probably more like
seven but it was in a one huge trash
bag and uh it was like not passable at
all well what it was was uh he said it
had had mites spidermites and once have
spidermites like you could during the
grow you like burn sulfur or I can't
remember what they burn they burn some
[__] and it kills it off but it also
leaves a weird taste and um he had all
that all that uh close trim close nug
trim Lea that's what people blast it
back then to make oil and shatter and uh
he's like bro I can't like morally run
this and I'm like you shouldn't have it
here either though like it's
it's like moldy like want throw the fire
pit I'm like the fire outside your house
he's in the country so I'm
like yeah I do I do want to throw all
this weed in the fire but that sounds so
sick and as before we do it I go you
know how many people are going to be mad
at us that could have lasted me for I
don't care if it had mine I could have
lasted me you know what that could have
ungrateful I hate living in Kansas man
oh man when I get oh God I already knew
how I was going to do it and that's
exact what happened people just hated on
me so hard but also cool little clip
what about Edibles no now if it has that
on that I don't want to I don't want to
be eating that for all our non-vegans
out there does it bother you oh for SP
no no no just like cobwebs mold this
like just not [__] you
want actual plant [__] you find a
nature
yeah all right what's this we have here
cbx one is
Casino Kush and then something else MZ
something I can't remember but they're
both really good the last one was fire I
wish I Ros would have told me which was
which um okay on to the next picture sir
here we go half pound joints dizzy wght
music video This should say but I felt
weird this should say half pound joint
dizzy W and burner music
video but at the time I felt kind of odd
I didn't that person on the right is is
burner in the thumbnail oh snap that
blurred out image with the bald guy in
the black hoodie that's burner right
there wow and I blurred it cuz I was
like I don't want to have in my
thumbnail but I'm not going to not use
this picture it's hard this picture is
on the history they use on the History
Channel this exact thumbnail they use it
on the History Channel I was like did
they ask no
a um oh actually it was through a
company and they asked me sorry what did
they use it for they were talking about
uh the boom of cannabis industry and
they were talking about how social media
blah blah blah and they showed this
picture uh viral videos and blah blah
blah seems to be a great way to do this
BL bunch of [__] Mass Roots was like
a like a weed Tube before weed Tu it was
mass frots and it was like weed
Instagram it was big for a while I
actually have a couple hundred shares in
that that were worth nothing but they G
you know how I knew that the tank it was
going to tank
I don't mean to put you out there I'm
sorry for anybody that worked there or
owned it you know how I knew when your
company wasn't going to make
it I walked into your party that you
probably spent 30k on it was a nice
party nice house in the Hills before
like right when I move the picture of me
like this with the homies for Life shirt
lighting that big ass joint outside mhm
that's the same day the same day other
side of that picture there's [__] 70
people standing there so
it's just angles it's just angles I was
in the backyard no I'm in a party with
hell of people around me uh so I'm
liting that gigantic
joint so hold on sorry I walk in and
this is like I said this is when I knew
like oh you guys are not going to make
it as a
company I walk in and they're like yo
here's a gift bag also here's 100 shares
of Mass Roots here's 100 shares of our
stock they were giving them out as FY
favors
shares of their company was it worth
anything at the time I don't
know still it's a lot did you just give
me some of your company as I walk into
your door would it feel like I'm
good why would you do that I don't know
I felt so odd and I oh
thanks that's a cool
gift it wasn't just to me they were
giving them out to a lot of people it
wasn't like damn Thomas you're special I
don't care if I was turned into a board
it was
like you have a joint in your hand
there's a wall of duts there's doughnut
wall where you go up and pick a donut
Off the Wall there's a joint rolling
station and you're giving away
stock
cool you guys are going to be around for
much longer sorry that's how they use
that picture what a backstory of no
there's no reason for the back story I
gave it to you so right there on the
right is burner blurred out cuz I didn't
you know I mean I felt weird then be
like yeah you're using them for you know
for clicks this is 7 years ago I post
this I don't even care about YouTube
anyway I thought it was pretty funny
full circle that is the burner and dizzy
right song go ahead so if you go watch
type in on Google or on YouTube burnard
DIY right that's the
song that's me you seen me a couple
times in the music video hitting the
joint with the big joints and [__]
that's
me and uh when I got there it was very
awkward because me and we had that
awkwardness mhm but dizzy introduced me
to him I was like oh no like you said
like I've been around him a lot I wasn't
sure like I was in Frisco we're doing
the music video shoot and I was with
them for like 2 hours this music video I
get there Aussie we as we should smoke
Aussie uh the ztics pictures you've been
seeing with the guy with the long hair
Li the huge joint that's Aussie he was
one of the first uh Instagram weed guys
with me his name is we should smoke he R
huge joints and those are both his he
rolled both of those joints oh [__] so
he's like take a picture actually
Aussie's behind me ducked down cuz he
did this and he's like all right take
your
picture and he's actually behind me
ducked down in the video that video you
can actually see it it's funny dude like
I just I don't know I thought it was
cool anyway that's the video that's me
if you want to go watch that I think
it's called I can see you needed it or I
can tell you needed it one of the two
yeah shout out to DIY right another
great episode at the other Studio at the
other
Studio okay
this next video is my very first Vlog
shopping video I I will never sit here
and be like I started that Trend I'm not
going to say that but I'm going to say
this is the first time I ever did it and
it's the
first let me take you the audience the
give you an experience that you can't
get unless you're in California let me W
and that's the first time I talked to
the camera on a vlog as I as as it was a
person that's how I kind of started
associating it like that video I talked
to the camera as if you were my friend
on
FaceTime so that video right there I
just take you through through through uh
dispenser you know buy a bunch of stuff
check out a bunch of stuff I don't even
think I bought a bunch of stuff I just
checked out a bunch of stuff this is Mr
Nice Guys right there in your right by
you um this is my first video that ever
hit a million views wow I had no I
wasn't a big YouTuber or nothing I think
I had like TW 40,000 was this one had
that giant uh grass field in it you had
to walk across freaking football field
this is the same place yeah the same
place I walked in there
like it's right by like a Carl Jr or
something some [__] yeah like restaurant
by it in Santana they're all along one
street right by thousand of them yeah
yeah that's
it uh but yeah that I just wanted to
talk about this cuz this is what sparked
me to go do people want to like Vlog
with me with instead of of just do like
videos that are stagnant and stationary
like stationary videos where I'm just
sitting here telling you
stuff or do PE and that's what made me
think I'll try it let me try it I did
that video I edited on my phone cut it
together and when I put it out great
response people loved it like yo more of
this and that's back when I could I
could do it still but I answer every
single comment of every single video
before I move on to the next post while
it's uploading I answer every single
comment from the video before you know
it's was usually only like 100 off cuz I
was I kept up but that was like I think
I was like four or 5,000 comments every
single one of them answered and that's
like the past nine months and then I
just gave up but that's back when I had
more time but I just I'm just looking
back at like wow that's what sparked my
vlogging this right
here which is a big part of my channel
did you know that going into it or was
it just by chance that like no after I
got done filming I went that was fun
that that was
cool first time I had a videographer the
person filming this is uh the guy that
owns munchies and secret vegan pizza and
naughty Panda my homie that does all the
vegan restaurants this is him right here
he's actually filming it for me nice
yeah now he owns hella restaurants it's
just crazy is he like balling out of
control or is restaurant owning out like
that he does so much bro he owns a
couple buildings he does oh he does
a it's him and his me and they they they
they put on everything they're just they
work their ass off they're just doing
marketing for Wii
companies uh he was paying me for a
video from a company we went to the bank
it was like 400 bucks I like oh hell
yeah good
[__] and uh we're standing there at the
bank and he said something about like a
vegan cheese and I go oh you're vegan he
goes yeah I go me too man I've been
vegan for like maybe like two years but
it's hard dude I told my kid it's hard
man and he goes nacho Che I'm like you
can make vegan nacho cheese out of a
cashew like what do you mean you make it
out of a cat no stop stop what do you
mean and that's when he's like I'll text
you the recipe he text me the recipe and
that's why I started making my Nao
cheese for like two years I was making
cheese all the time out of cashew cheese
it was bomb and I and I I made it one
time and I told him like bro this is so
good blah blah blah you should you
should jar it mhm he like uh maybe he
just doing weed marketing content for
people like being the guy putting it
together and he Jarred it and sold it
he's like yo people bought it I'm like
that's great that's spum and then he's
like I think I'm G to try to make
something he made a little hot pocket
and he started selling them at a at a
local grocery store and he started
selling them and it was like he's like
dude they they sold like cuz they're
good dude if you care people will care
and then um
he started making more of them he
started making more of them he's like
dude I think I'm G do like a little
popup out of out of like a ridiculous he
I'm going do a popup at a at a food like
a food fair I'm like yeah you should
he's like I'm GNA call it Munchies I go
yeah it's one my favorite restaurants
yeah bomb right and he's like uh yeah
okay I'm G try it and he did good the
first day I went and I mean obviously I
went bought [__] and then uh and this is
when I was like damn this 400 SA save me
right now like that $400 was came in so
clutch so for me to even go buy I just
had to I was like D I have the money to
buy this [__] I want to do it and then
he's like yo I'm going get a little
store for I'm like what and it was like
a bunch of restaurants in a building but
he had like like a window and he cooked
behind served the window he did that for
like eight
months and then he told me like dude I'm
going to do more food fair pop up like
hell yeah and they started doing more
food fair then you got a little spot a
little like this big in Santa
Ana and then him and his homie are like
put more his homie is like a very big
photographer like he does super sick
[__] and uh he's like dude I'm GNA do it
then he got his restaurant and then he
got a bigger spot I'm like
dude what and then he got a real
restaurant the one he has then he opened
up his pizza spot then he opened up his
other spot then he opened up another one
wow all like back to back to back to
back to
back all off of a conversation uh
talking about after one of these little
videos and the video what the video was
was a the Shark Tank video I did M the
sh the fake shark tank pitch where I was
selling weed that video and then we went
to the bank to get something for another
brand wow yeah so that might not have
really happened no just I mean I mean
I'm not saying we're responsible for
that I'm saying like how random a little
baby conversation you think so like dude
this is good I'd buy
it I would that's why you got to follow
your intuition something hits your brain
like that buy this and what did I say do
do you think people want hear me
talk yeah I'll try it I'll try I did my
first story times never talked to camera
[__] it I'll try I'll grow light in my
phone M from this angle all dumb from
low looking down and uh I us do that
then I like in one of my classes they
were like sun comes or light comes from
the Sun from above so we're going to put
our lights up here and I was like that
makes sense yeah makes perfect sense
unless you look
scary um but yeah anyway I thought that
was really wild that's how all that
happened onto this this I dropped three
years
ago okay going on
four I think I dropped it right before
right as 2020 was
happening and I had just uh fire or got
like got away from my guy I remember
this had just come out right when I came
around exactly so this car tune story
time here we go here's the full
backstory here's all of it this is how
it's going to go down are you
ready I used to have another
videographer he was cool um he films for
a really big
comedian does his thing does music video
shoots there's a lot of cool stuff he's
like a Matt Alonzo baby light Matt
Alonzo but just filming MH not all the
production anyway um he knows this dude
and he does show running for ComEd he
does all he's the guy that does the
comedy oh uh Russell Peters is coming
all right I'm going to direct to the
show because this is Comedy Central
presents I'm going to direct it I'm
going to do the stage I'm going to do
this I'm do the LI I'm going to edit put
it out he's the showrunner for Comedy
Central of of the standups yeah so I'm
like oh cool that's dope uh my
videographer told him about me he
checked it out he goes yeah this guy's
actually really funny like all right and
that's the guy I did my five minutes for
remember I had that I was doing the
standup [__] I was like I have a bunch
of [__] right now he goes really do five
minutes I and I did it and he's like
it's funny but here's where you need to
tighten this I would drop this in here
maybe maybe picked it up here I was like
that's it he goes pretty good like God
thank God thank God I was really sced I
was outside of a restaurant in Hollywood
just doing this for this [__] guy I
did and he's like pretty good never did
it like yeah never did it yes and
uh um anyway I told him about story time
cuz this when story time just started
and he's like I watch your story time
like the videos are funny man and he's
that that kind of guy he's not like I
loved he's like it was good he's one of
those like very laid-back dudes anyway
he goes what about a cartoon and I go
I've been wanting to do a cartoon he
goes I think this would be a real good
cartoon and I know if we get one to two
we can go to Netflix with it I'm like
what' you just say all right let's run
it so we got an animator I'm not going
to get too into the animation and what
they do and who they do stuff for but
they do stuff for other
people didn't mesh too well with the guy
he was
cool but like I'm like yo I look like a
tweaker and he didn't like like that oh
like you gave me a tweaker face like we
should we should probably like maybe
eyelids it's in the eyes and the smile
yeah maybe eyelids and not
yeah
I look like the robots from uh RoboCop 3
the the Asian Samurai Robot guys dead by
the ey yeah and
uh you look like you're really sorry for
something you're horribly running away
from yeah it looks
scary anyway there's so much back and
forth so much back and forth so much
back and forth we posted this and said
guys here's a little clip and it was
just me running through some things very
very trash animation I think oh I didn't
really I didn't not no the mov M and
everything was not I didn't like it Goa
like Johnny Bravo shits on that and uh
anyway we put this cartoon story timeout
to get people like excited get the
interest see if they like it huge
response all anybody could talk about on
my DM for for months was when is your
story I still get people where's the
cartoon story time at all the time as if
they as if I dropped this 10 10 days ago
like yo what's that story time like that
was 3 years ago I've updated you guys 60
times since so many other videos I've
updated and people you know it's not
it's not their fault I they just want to
know I get irritated about I'm just like
what come
on um so what we did was we put a pitch
together and what happened
was this guy was really just trying to
ride my wave and make money he's like
all right 15,000 an episode I'll keep
eight we put five in I'm
like what' you stop stop he's like you
know what I'm gonna edit and do
everything I
go oh you think I'm stupid okay I didn't
realize you thought I was dumb keep
going tell me your pitch and then he
said it I was like that's dumb anyway
let's go get this and we had to get
sponsors for it I was not making
anything I was barely making money with
push trees this is still the time before
I was I I started putting it into hyper
gear and trying to do [__] right before
I met you and uh those were your first
sponsorships what like videos when we
started working
together maybe like a couple months
before like the superb and the stizzy
and all that maybe a couple months
before I met
you man I never made a dollar before I
met you Marty then you showed me your
page and I go I'll get it done
somehow that's it that's when I met you
I still was like yo I got to make
rent I'm telling you dude I met you and
it was still like that apartment was my
film room my side room my spare room my
squish room my storage room my
everything and puss trees's inventory
like yep all that all that [__] in one
room um so uh that's the room I learned
that you can't violently rip a pen and
then try to quietly stand behind the
camera and hold in a cough for a [__]
20 minute take yeah it doesn't work that
way it was a fun it was fun every was
cool
um oh sorry get the sponsorship packages
down we're going to make 20 bands an
episode and it's going to cost us 14 15
blah blah blah so there was my profit of
it I was like Wow
$6,000 I'm what she losing my mind like
why that's so much [__] money to make
on a video oh my
God pitch it to Raw to stizzy to uh like
four other huge Brands I knew all of
them 100% on board all of them like yes
how much five count as S I go so 5,000
package 6,000 package the the 7,000
package whatever the highest package I
wear your branded shirt during the
episode in the
cartoon 3,000 I maybe I and during the
video I'm like ripping your [__] your
maybe I'm ripping your brand so I'm just
with my
friend just says like yeah like somehow
make it tight you make it cool like dude
is he wearing a raw shirt in the big
like yeah raw sponsored this episode at
the end That's all folks thanks to raw
papers for sponsoring the episode and a
little me cartoon away so fun so what
happened everybody's like yeah let's do
it and then they go all all of them by
the way every single company went our
lawyer said no every single kids they
said it's a cartoon and it it can be
misconstrued as kid for kids we can't
sponsor anything get backlash on us and
I went oh my God you're
right and then I found another animator
and they go 14k an episode I go how long
is the episode 16 minutes I went no I
can't do that dude I I literally can't
my rent is 23 and can you help me I need
help with this rent I'm trying to come
up right now yeah come on
man help me a 14k episode for thing I
don't make money on no thanks and that's
when I first started doing stuff with
company
so anyway guys that didn't happen here
you go that didn't happen because of it
and that's why the Christmas I mean the
Christmas story time the cartoon story
time is not here I don't want to give a
full I don't want to give it away but I
love animated shows there's there's like
five animated shows I love and I'll tell
you Al camera but one of our friends ran
into one of the animators at a party
from one of these shows that is now
retired that says
I'll help you I'll give you a shot he
told him about my story time cartoons
like I'll give it a shot I work
something out tell you which to show
after but it's it's one of my it's a top
10 animated shows ever and one of the
guys one of the animators is now retired
it's like yeah I'll help you out he's
like happens to be like weed adjacent M
anyway so hopefully we get that animated
story time next year a little pilot and
that's how we set season six off starts
off with me this is my idea starts off
with me doing my hey guys this how I'm
going to introduce it like all right
let's get started and like episode one
just like almost like when Alan parish
and
Jumanji his hand start going but like it
starts getting drawn
over washes over like page master and it
goes into top
view down into wherever I'm doing it so
the story starts off oh my God MH every
great movie starts off the top view down
American Beauty Force gum pants past a
couple gang bangers their scures
by beginning Friday punch from you yeah
beginning of Friday yeah lands on
you little fools running oh my God that
sounds
fun that sounds so fun all right so back
on topic see look it 1 minute 7 Seconds
long the last video the cartoon Story
Time 4 minutes and 6 seconds 1 15
seconds of it was a cartoon the rest of
it was me explaining what the cartoon
was about a minute and 7 Seconds look it
5 years ago I did not care about YouTube
isn't that nuts yeah that is weird just
five years ago couldn't care
less yeah um so this video I mean it's
pretty blatant what it is this video is
called throwing five pounds of weed off
stage it's exactly what it is all right
I team the people uh I was going to
release push tre's cannabis with a long
time ago end up I did one booth with
them it did great and they you guys owe
me a lot of money you can just hang on
to it it's fine
um they had their grower homies and they
were going to help us and blah blah blah
anyway these guys were just trapping
they had 100 piece there's a bunch of
stuff they're trapping it out just at
the booth I was at my booth and they
come up and go yo you want to go on
stage and help us out and my hand go no
I do not want to go on stage at all like
I don't want to be up there remember I
told you I posted one event and I stood
on the side of the
stairs that [__] made me feel
uncomfortable that's weird and then we
did Ted talk I'm like oh that's fine
uhuh now I don't care at all in any way
shape or form about any kind of stress
or no you guys want to not have fear go
do something horrifying go do the most
scariest thing ever the TK talkk was so
damn scary I just saw a picture on my
phone the one of me looking at my my
notes walking and then you sitting down
looking at your notes and it stressed me
out so so bad oo I don't ever want to be
there again I don't think I've been
tired since then even uh another Ted
Talk would not be as stressful no it be
it'd be way fun but I never want to do
that be in that mind we weren't meant to
try to rememorize the speech three days
before we rewrote our entire speech
three days before the the the event we
talked about it but that gives me
anxiety like like like like this middle
of the semester and I have don't know
what's going on before the Ted Talk it
was literally me in my closet with my
laptop recording it trying to play back
listen to it with the Q cards like we
both had a stack of Q cards imagine 20
minutes worth of [__] you're trying to
remember I forba hated it dude oh my God
I'd rather go back to school it was like
that it was so much worse than that
though it makes me feel scared and like
just like cuz you're like oh they got 40
what is it 40 million on their Channel
what yeah okay yeah let good L people
people are going to see this been
talking about this a while what means I
don't like messing stuff up yeah and if
I have to memorize four page
like okay okay let's
go I can't memorize any of this [__] as
I fuing smok remember my notes no okay
here we go here we go throwing P five
pounds off stage they say hey do you
want to come up and I go yeah I'll go on
stage I'll
go and I here here's five pounds went oh
I feel so much better I was like okay I
like what do you want to do with them
like throw them into the crowd I go
what' you say just throw them in the
crowd say it again you want me to throw
these pounds of
weed into the
crowd they're keeping them goes man just
throw them I all right all right he's
said film it if you can though okay so
that's me throwing five PS and I think
it was a couple like half
PES I got one video from the dude in in
the back that got the pee like a days
later I threw full vacuum sealed pounds
into a crowd at the High Times Cannabis
Cup handfuls I threw full
peas at a time a pound a pound just it
and got a whole pound yes
damn the the one that went in the very
back cuz I threw it like this and I I
frisbe it it flew back that guy ripped
it open started handing it out to
everyone what a g somebody got a video
of him and they're right next to him in
the back and the gu's just doing
this everybody me I'm Sparta kicking
fools out the way I'm out of there not
done the guy in the front as you can see
the pound going he bear hugged at the
bottom bear hugged it caught the whole
thing like a trash bag just tucked away
and I think he took off the person in
left side didn't find out till later got
the [__] beat out of him fools just
started fighting each other over it and
somebody
won that's what happened not like
somebody got jumped somebody started
fighting each other for it uhuh and then
I felt real stupid then I went oh yeah
that's that's like a that's rent right
there what were we do and then I looked
him go what were we thinking we should
have did ounces man we should have
bagged up ounces and chucked them out
and he goes you know what you're right I
I'll probably never do that again that
was sounds kind of dangerous actually I
went yeah the guy got beat the shipping
at him I didn't think about it till
after like someone's going to get shot
you not get shot because you have to get
you have to get you know scanned in
you're not going to bring your gun in
but people somebody got the somebody got
their ass beat right there I threw a
pound to the right and that's all I
remember I feel so dumb I will never do
that again no got pounded out for that
pound yep
bad
o anyway that's the video on to the next
you
ready let's see what's next oh here we
go here we go guys this is called I did
a Mini commercial for Netflix I didn't
do [__] for
Netflix oh yeah I did but it's not like
they were like yo Thomas I need you to
do this for me sounded better than the
title I think right it's compelling I
think it was a better it was a better
better and the reason why I felt like it
was okay I'll give you the story so this
show is the show called disjointed and
it was on Netflix
I did not think it was
funny anyway the actors and actresses in
the show were great I I like them the
show just didn't do it it just wasn't
for me it's a read show I just yes I
just didn't like it I don't I don't know
I don't know something was off about it
all right but Mrs bue right there she's
right there miss bue was in it all right
so here we go Dr Dena Dr Dena is um she
owns a dispensary she's been on Vice Dr
Dena she's like snoops weat dealer that
chick you ever see the I've definitely
heard of her Dr Dina yeah she's cool
she's my homie she was the producer or
like the person that comes in it makes
it look real they hired her as like
legitimate Factor yeah like come in and
make sure this is looks good yeah
because this is a wi culture we cannot
rest it up so Dr Dena was part of this
show so she invited me to the Netflix
Premiere right she invited me to the
premere and they gave me an invitation
and you know me before I had all these
damn businesses and a bunch of time and
not a dollar I'm sitting there going
what can I do with this this invitation
they gave me and then I made a whole
commercial out of it took 5 and 1 half
hours to film from one invitation and
I'll tell you what it was they gave me a
medicine bottle like a/ qu ounce
medicine bottle and inside like a like a
weed bottle okay and inside of it was
like a rolled up invitation that's cool
it was very cool and it had inside said
Netflix in the bottle like in the
paper so I was
like what can I do with this invitation
that's going to make Netflix let go who
is
this so what I did was do you remember
the old Chef boy D commercial where they
dropped the can the can just rolls
through all walks of life it's at the
beach it's a going through a wedding
it's going through this it's going
through that blah blah blah it's an old
commercial right I think it was I'm
pretty sure was Chef boy Rd I just redid
that I was like you know what let's do
the weed version of Chef boy Rd so I
started off at Echo Park and I dropped
up and it rolled it went through OG's
neighborhood it went through Bob's
neighborhood I
drove all the away to Bobs he doesn't
live around here to get one shot in
front of his white picked
fence one two second shot and then drove
an hour and a half
back I went everywhere I went to a
certain Mall just to get it on the
escalator so I can get the shot of it
coming over the horizon into frame
rolled it rolled it rolled it rolled it
had nugs in it you know I mean I what it
was is me rolling joint I put my joint
jar down and I went oh and it rolled off
the ledge
and just took off right it was a fun
video dude very [__] it was very fun
video anyway it ends at OG's that girl
that's OG's daughter it ends at OG's and
the it's like this the camera's right
here and the jar rolls stops Netflix I
did that 90 times that's a real shot MH
I rolled it and did this okay it'll stop
there and there was a little crack I'm
like all
right so
so damn frustrated the whole time but I
got the shot that was a real shot when
you watch this that was a real
shot send I post it Dean hits me up like
oh my God that was th that was so fun
and then she's like what time you going
to be here and I was like I'm be there
at 6 o'clock she like Okay blah BL BL
blah I get there I meet four Netflix
Executives all follow me already before
I made this
video interesting how random all four
Dudes already followed me and I sh I was
shaking their hand they're
like that commercial was so fun and I'm
like you saw the commercial like that
was awesome and the other guyy was like
dude epic I was like oh yes thank you
guys and I was like y when tell yeah I
do content like bro we follow you and I
oh and my head like shut
up you follow me all of you guys give me
a damn show already in my head and then
um they walk away and then Dean's like
they're all dicks they were fanboying
out before you walked up and you walked
up then they try to play it cool all of
them said they would that's what they
wanted to do they wanted to do something
fun but they not allowed to do wi
content for Netflix even though it's a
weed show but they couldn't do it for
their socials it's like they were just
fanboying out and then you walked up
then they tried to play all cool I was
like yeah I'm glad to hear that also
come on what the [__] put me on the show
or something
what's going on I'm going to say it now
ex Cod did a piece on it and that's how
I found out who ex Cod was they stole
exco's identity and put a character in
there that was mimicking him same hat
and everything damn it he was a streamer
in the show mhm it was really just him
it was just supposed to be ex it was
that's how I found out who he was I saw
Netflix stealing my Identity or
something I go who is this and then he
was funny like who is this guy and then
when I started Netflix I me I started
doing YouTube like oh it's the dude just
jointed stole and then I started
listening go story time is funny mhm and
that's how I knew who ex Cod was um so
yeah that I took it uh I think I
privated
it because I thought that the show was
so bad I just didn't want to be
associated with it so you probably not
I'll unprivate it just so you guys can
watch it okay by the time this comes out
but yeah I hated it I haven't I don't
know any of the show bad show not funny
all right last one yep here we go this
is called the $100,000 weed shopping
spree
legally
okay I don't like flying and that is the
Burbank jetu Airport to go to
Vegas I was actually about oh wa not to
go to Vegas to go to Santa Ana I mean
Santa Rosa this was going
to um what's the the event holif flowers
thank you so the owner of cure company
OG you know runs the Cure company uh
dispensary the owner of cure company uh
we're talking to like yeah we should do
a video blah blah and I was like I'm
about to go to Hall of flowers he goes
do you want to just do a video at Hall
of flowers and remember this is two and
a half months before I started making
any kind of money in any in any way I
should
perform and
um he goes we you just go get a jet I go
yeah pretty sure he goes no we'll just
buy private and I go what he goes you
know not private let's get jet Suite I
go what does that mean I didn't know jet
Suite meant and he's like we'll get on a
plane me you and OG and we'll go to Hall
of flowers you'll be my buyer and I go
what do you mean he's
like I will give you a certain amount of
money and you go buy cuz he owns like 18
stores like you go buy the stuff you
think is fire and I will put it on my
shelves because I trust you I
go okay how much you want me to spend
he's like 20 and OG looked at him he
goes what 30 he goes I go I don't know
man like I don't know how much you want
to spend I don't have any money in my
head I'm like I don't even I don't have
money I don't know what you want to
spend and he
goes make it 100 and in my head I'm like
shut up stop go just you have $100,000
to play with just go do it and I'm like
all right
cool and then we get then we we get on
the plane and OG's stressing out just
like I am and uh I'm about to get
playing right after they tell the story
too I my literally my Uber is 15 minutes
away which is nuts I hate this hate
plane rides anyway um G we get on the
plane all good we go out there we filmed
this video this is the last thing I ever
filmed with the guy that I told you I
don't don't work with anymore he's a
jerk this came out four months after I
filmed it because he extorted me for the
for the footage and I had to pay him to
get my own footage back I remember that
yeah um extorted my ass for my own
footage and I was like you know what I
am so broke I care about my content so
much that I will pay you to get my [__]
back and I did and I got my other video
that I was waiting for him so here's the
video that I think is well worth it
because I bought my own video which is
crazy first video I edited first thing
Marty ever did for me wasn't that nuts
last thing he ever did first thing you
ever did crazy this video is great all
right so I go throughout the entire the
entire spot I meet I met Shava like a
year before this like in an interview
just in like passing we didn't really
you know do much but I saw him here
again and he was so awesome and I'm like
you know we should hang out and then
that's how that's now how I know sha we
know shabo right so I met shavo during
this episode met a bunch of people go
just watch the watch the video it's it's
fun go through the whole thing shopping
um and that's when I was like oh my God
Seth Rogan I saw Seth Rogan there I was
like oh she my height he's like a little
shorter than me holy [__] and then
that's when I called my guy I was
working like yo Seth Rogan's out here
blah blah blah blah you should come out
here but like he se he was actively
[__] on a guy like get away from me
to a guy that came up to him not in a
bad way I am 100% on Seth Rogan side the
guy came up to him in the middle of an
event while people were taking pictures
with him and try to run a business
proposal for a trap brand and he goes
yeah yeah you should ask me about that
right here in front of everyone and the
guy's
like yeah he goes yeah you you should
keep doing that you should keep asking
me about the illegal stuff in front of
all these
people and he went oh okay and he walked
off and I was like oh Seth Rogan I like
you because I would have said the same
damn thing to him also I don't know if I
want to try to talk to because I was I
was like should I try to interview him
for the video MH and that's back when I
was out doing stuff where I got
traumatized by the 50,000 subscriber
gave away when everybody was so mean to
me I I went up to so many people so many
people were so mean and rude to me that
I just didn't want to do out and about
stuff anyone I was like I don't want to
be around and then the pandemic hit I'm
like I don't really want to go around
nobody now anyway that's why I want to
do so much stuff out I got to get back
into it but anyway I see Seth Rogan and
as I called the guy the guy I used to
work with he's like I'm be right there
and then as I hung up he was [__] on
this guy and he did not look happy after
I was like oh I don't know if I want to
be the first time I meet you is 10
seconds after you tell a guy to eat a
dick I don't think I can I don't know
and then here comes the guy I'm working
with running out he's like go talk I'm
like bro you did not just see what
happened I don't we should leave him
alone and he started losing his mind
that I wouldn't do it and I was like
this is my channel what are you you I
don't think you understand your position
in the terms of suggestions not demands
I will punch you in your face in my head
I'm like should I hit him the way he was
acting I'm like I think I should knock
his ass out right here because the way
he was acting was like all the
aggression of fighting without hitting I
was like you and and the whole time just
trying to keep it cool I'm like
yeah anyway I didn't talk to Seth Rogan
and he walked straight into a room I was
like yeah and then he lost it on he's
like you didn't even talk to him I lost
my mic running over here that's your
fault I'm like say it again I lost my
mic on my way over here my fault I like
that's insane you know that right it's
$200 you to buy you have to buy it for
me now I like okay yeah we'll talk about
that later and then I think that night
is when um I told you the story but
that's the night when I was like peace
and that's the video so that that that
this video sparked off to me shopping
sprees in the end because the first
shopping spree was vlogging remember I
was like that people want to see me Vlog
and do stuff this is what got me like
going I was doing th000 shopping spree
it was $100,000 and then that's what
sparked the ,000 shopping spre here
th000 sh he prizzy th I was just looking
at videos like wow this out what sparked
a lot of stuff and then what happened
transition over to the podcast and now
here we are which is crazy but yeah
that's how this all started I wanted to
go through some of these videos just
because I was thinking like what's my
game plan how am I going to rework this
for to be appeasing of YouTube and as I
was looking through them earlier I'm
like I remember that
day yeah I'm G tell a story about I'm
going to go through my whole I'm going
go through my list so I just grabbed
like eight or nine of them I don't know
it's a cool idea I didn't know a lot of
this stuff yeah about I mean every
single video has a story to it everyone
and I
remember I remember 85% of filming
everything it's not like I don't
remember anything about each day 85% of
all these videos I remember everything
about the day but there's like 15% where
I'm
like I don't really remember that day
very well but I remember filming exactly
how I am with like albums and songs yeah
yeah so that's how that's how I was
thinking but yeah all right what are we
at time wise oh my God
150 Oh I thought said 105 I was like we
did
it okay you know what I was like today's
the first 1:30 cuz I actually have to
go on a flight so it's like I actually
have to be at an hour or 30 but we did
two hours so that's okay but yeah guys
today was a a catchup episode because
next week is the Brad Williams episode
and then the Christmas episode with
Franklin which is kind of funny we
thought about it we only have four
opportunities a month to talk to you
guys next season hopefully maybe we can
add an you know an extra episode of a
week that would be epic if it's just
Marty nights that would have to be a
solo episode there's no way we can
double guest in one week that's that's
just we need a team at that point I
don't know we're going to figure it out
but guys thank you so much for being
here uh you have anything else party no
I appreciate you guys appreciate all the
nice comments and all the support on
these past two episodes you been putting
out a lot of personal [__] so I
appreciate you guys always being so nice
and just supportive and keep it pushing
this New
Year those joints got him because that
was a Comon you ever
been also we only smoke two joints a
piece they were kind of fatter but hey I
counting those five in the ad raid oh
yeah we're diying it back a little bit
trying to cuss so hard but we're still
talking we're still here we're trying to
we're trying to experiment guys we're
trying to you already know and if you're
in the chat and you're watching watching
you already part of this community and
you know exactly what's going on with us
you know exactly where it took and what
it took to get here so thank you for
being here looking at these thumbnail I
gotta I gota get outside more man so
much more fun doing videos just going
places sorry I'm all off topic thank you
guys so much for being here do us a
favor go follow the Instagram the uh
dope as usual podcast excuse me go
follow the Twitter go follow the Tik Tok
and obviously uh dope as usual podcast
Clips what are we at 70k yep just passed
thank you guys cuz our watch time is
high people are here to stay you guys
are hanging out with us thank you all
right we've been here for two hours we
appreciate you for Marty and I guys this
has just been a catchup episode solo
talking about a bunch of random things
and uh dude that flew by yeah it did it
did huh it really flew by you never have
a heart out oh yeah cuz I I actually
have to leave yeah so thank you guys so
much for being here I appreciate you
from Marty and I this has been the dope
as usual podcast if if you have a homie
that hasn't watched send him an episode
send him your favorite episode actually
what's your F leave it in the comments
what's your favorite episode one pick
one put the season or the number or the
name I want to know what your guys's
favorite episode is because the goat
episode's our biggest one yet yeah but
what's your favorite one
yeah interested to know that too thank
you guys so much for being here we
appreciate you from Mar O'Neal this been
do us podcast have a dope ass
[Music]
day
perfect
[Music]